we are so excited because we are now
going to talk about Marvel Studios
Avengers damage control Davis sure how
you doing good man
yeah you guys it's I'm good to see you
too I saw the press release come in or
this learning that we were gonna that
you guys were gonna announce this year
for like at the time for New York Comic
Con yep got so excited yep
how excited are you I'm super excited we
have been working on it for a long time
and I think what's the most exciting
thing is when we finished when we
finished wrapping the press materials at
2:30 this morning and went to bed and
got up and then it was you know on the
internet when the trailer hit the most
exciting thing is the fan reaction to
the idea of it and the suit designs
people are freaking out which is amazing
to see the Iron Man wakandan mix and all
the comments is it's really exciting to
see people genuinely excited for wait
what is this is new this is cool so I
think that's the important part it's new
yeah and it's cool and like you in the
trailer that we see that those two suits
the color schemes it it looks like
familiar but new and I think that's
gonna be cool and there's a lot still a
lot of questions because I'm still a lot
to explain or see I think more
importantly experience right yes and on
the suits kudos goes to Ryan my nerding
and Phil Saunders of the visual come on
guys unbelievable I mean Ryan's been
there forever and and Phil unbelievable
job in the suit designs but that that
idea of new for us in the studio we were
working on it in in brainstorming it was
this opportunity to explore a whole new
corner of the Marvel Universe where it's
like okay we've never done anything in
VR we've never told a story in VR we've
never brought our actors and our
characters into into VR what's that like
what's it going to be like doing this
with a totally new technology the
interesting part of it was so much of it
translates from the filmmaking side of
things you know when we do things on set
with the actors Medusa capture facial
capture we used a lot of those same
things in bringing this to life you know
some of the actors went through that
which was amazing so you're getting the
real-life performance of the actor
in the experience but outside of that
it's being able to bring this this thing
to life for people that you know people
have waited years and years years to see
some of their characters on the screen
you see Black Panther in Civil War it's
like oh my god I've been reading about
that my whole life and and I and then
now it's like wait I get to mark a
moment in time where I get to step into
the MCU you know people who follow a
time okay this happened over here this
happened over there okay and on October
18th I actually teamed up with the
Avengers stepped into the universe and
and assembled alongside them you know
the the early fan reactions we've gotten
from some of the test screenings it been
extraordinarily phenomenally positive
but also externally powerful in people's
reactions to you go to a Disney theme
park you go to a movie you get to meet
those characters you get to watch those
characters come to life and now you get
to team up with them so it's pretty
pretty fun yeah before we continue on my
producer is shaking a placard at us say
there's a video that we can share the
trailer we could show the jet we can
show the trailer why are you running the
trailer and the world is evolving
[Music]
while Conda is looking for the most
qualified recruits to test my latest
prototype design
the time is now
[Music]
we need you
[Music]
are you ready let's get you suited up
[Music]
yes yes give me more of that what I love
at the end there we see ILM xlab and the
void and those things are really crucial
really fun you know I I went and did the
Star Wars experience at the void lucre
to the empire yeah so cool and like that
feeling of like oh it's warm
I'm gonna fall over like yeah yeah
things and then playing Vader immortal
on on the oculus quest that ILM xlab did
and like that sense of this is a
different experience than I've ever felt
believes real like it is yeah it is that
that moment when you feel like oh this
is something different
I need to like I want to share this with
PDA I can't wait for that in the MCU
yeah that is the thing to like when you
get to go through the experience and
there's a lot more we have to share soon
you know more characters more things
you're gonna get to see and do but when
you step into those places that you've
always wanted to step into or characters
show up that you've always wanted to
meet there's heat there's wind there's
those things there's physical walls so
when you're in an iconic location which
is the book which is the fun part of it
we have ten years of iconic Marvel you
know cinematic universe locations to
visit there's a lot of new ones in this
but when those characters show up you
get those physical attributes
the other cool thing that we love about
it is no guns so you're in there you saw
the end of the trailer some of that
nanotech that Sheree has that we saw
with the stark suits you know I mean in
infinity war an end game that he's that
he's gotten and you know that was the
funding and brainstorming it was in a
post endgame world who would Tony trust
he was some of his tech you know maybe
you sure you got our hands on some of it
and proved a little bit tweaked it a
little bit you know of course she's
gonna have some fun with it
but that idea of being able to be in a
physical space have physical effects
like heat and wind and motion smells
sensory all those things that the void
does so well mixed with the amazing
ability that we have and in this
experience for the first time ever fully
gesture-based mechanics so if you put
your arm out like Iron Man
you know you have that nanotech black
panther suit on you can fire beams and
there's no controllers no so it's really
immersive in a way that we've never been
able to
greens before and so for MCU fans we
hope it's something that really takes it
to the next level and you talked about
it being new but the MCU too many fans
it's not new what so yeah they're
already all these thoughts yeah I mean
my brain is like percolate with all
these things I want to do so when you're
talking about all these iconic things I
feel like even the sound of like the
nanotech is like such a specific thing
what is that iconic elements if you're
looking to bring from the MCU and it's
funny you say that - because in a lot of
the immersive like research that we did
in things and working with X lab you
know again like getting to work with the
X lab team and going up to Lucas film as
a film fan first of all it's like wait
you're gonna let me in the building yeah
okay we have to win but but outside of
that when you're doing the testing in
the research people have thought about
picking up a lightsaber the whole life
people have thought about flying or a
pulsar beam like Iron Man they already
know what it sounds like they've seen it
they've heard it but that that instant
gratification and the feeling of when
you're the first the first time you get
to do it and the reactions we've gotten
and in VR where you're fully immersed in
it's your experience people come out and
they've gone through what is the longest
experience ever done for the void which
is super exciting but also is that
people you you think like okay what do
you think of this story and they're like
what do you mean like I was just like
the only remember firing beams like Iron
Man so it's like it's really funny in
the idea that you now get to take that
technology and the 10 years of
storytelling and Marvel Pantheon and
bring it together so Dave I have so many
more questions I have a lot of answers I
know but we can't share them because we
both like our jobs yeah yeah fans can
start checking out October 18th October
18 yep there's boys there's a bunch of
them you know we got New York they're
hanging over multiple locations yep New
York LA Atlanta there's more - more more
than I can mention then and yeah yeah go
online they're trailer watch it all and
I'm sure come the 18 boys are gonna get
rican out get your tickets at the void
calm now and yeah perfect yeah thank you
very much guys if I get it